one of the touching signs of the
influence of philosophy on everyday life
is that people can sometimes be heard to
complain that they're going through what
they call an existential crisis the
phrase maybe being used rather casually
and vaguely but it nevertheless touches
on one of the major traditions of
European philosophy closely associated
with the ideas of five philosophers in
particular Kierkegaard Kim Nietzsche
Heidegger and Saud though these thinkers
disagreed on many things
it is possible via their thought to come
to a coherent view of what an
existential crisis really is and when it
might therefore be helpful to refer to
ourselves as going through
the crisis is marked by five distinctive
features firstly it's a period when a
lot that it previously seemed like
common sense or normal reveals its
contingent chance uncanny and relative
nature for example we might start to
wonder why we live in this part of the
world rather than any other why we doing
this job and not something else why are
we with this partner and are following
this set of social norms in short we
realize rather disturbingly that there
are far more options beneath the surface
than we normally allow ourselves to
imagine we are freer than we thought
secondly this revelation is acutely
anxiety and you see a recognition of our
freedom doesn't bring with it calm quite
the opposite we recognize that I've been
deluding ourselves about what had to be
no one really cares quite as much as
we'd thought about what we are and have
chosen to do we could change everything
around we come to a disturbing awareness
that our ultimate responsibility is to
ourselves not the social world thirdly
we develop a heightened awareness of
death time is short and running out we
need to re-examine our lives but the
clock is ticking ever louder fourthly
and crucially for all the existential
philosophers we have many choices but
are by the nature of the human condition
denied the information we would need to
choose with ultimate wisdom or certainty
we are forced to decide it can never be
assured that we've done so adequately we
are steering blind and therefore we can
be guaranteed to make a lot of mistakes
the condition of mankind is to have to
plot our course in the dark without
adequate reason or insight this leads to
another favorite word for the
existentialists anxiety the human
condition is to be anxious not about
this or that particular thing but as a
basic feature of our lives because we
must always choose without any security
that we've chosen well and without
sufficient time to explore the options
this can all sound perilous and
dispiriting yet the existential
philosophers don't mean to depress us
they want to lend dignity and grandeur
to dilemmas which we too often think of
as ours alone and therefore feel ashamed
about as some personal curse when they
are in fact fundamental features of the
human condition which ennoble us when we
consider them with sufficient depth
the existentialist offer us a useful
corrective to a normal pin Isha's view
that intelligent choice might be
possible and untracked in structure an
existential approach tempers the modern
sentimental notion that perfection is
within reach that you suffer from the
agony of choice isn't some anomaly it's
one of the most predictable and poignant
things about being alive this is a
message we benefit from hearing quite
often because what helps with regret is
the knowledge that in fact every life is
burdened by it in some shape or form
literally on the regret free life exists
only in movies and songs the way to
diminish our anxiety and panic is to
alleviate the sense that one had the
option to choose correctly but failed a
degree of disappointment is at the
existential philosophers so beautifully
admitted just simply the human condition
you
you